Apple’s new 2nd generation AirPods are finally
here, but to be completely honest, they’re
a little bit underwhelming, at least compared
to all the leaks and rumors we’ve seen in
recent months.
There’s no active noise cancellation, no
health monitoring features, and worst of all,
they still only come in white.
But to be fair, Samsung’s new Galaxy Buds
also don’t get any of that apart from the
color options.
So if you’re trying to choose between both,
it’s really gonna come down to connectivity,
sound quality, and of course, price.
So before I get to who should upgrade to the
new AirPods and who shouldn’t, let’s quickly
run through all of the changes.
First up, of course, is the new Wireless charging
case, which is completely optional and will
work using any regular Qi charger.
The charging speed is still unknown but the
battery is comparatively small so it shouldn’t
take very long.
Next up, the AirPods finally have Hey Siri
support, so it’s much more convenient to
make calls, change the volume, or anything
else.
The way it works is by using a new accelerometer
which detects the motion of your jawbone when
you say the words “Hey Siri.”
Now here’s the big change, the new AirPods
pack Apple’s new H1 headphone chip, which
provides a faster and more stable wireless
connection to your devices.
Now the W1 chip in the original AirPods was
revolutionary, it seriously blew Bluetooth
out of the water with its quick connection
speed and battery life management.
The H1 chip boasts lowered latency, faster
connection time for phone calls and it can
switch between active devices up to 2x faster.
The only problem I have with my original AirPods
is that they take a while to connect to my
Mac, but thankfully, the $3 app called ToothFairy
fixed that issue.
So if the new H1 chip can solve these connection
issues, that’s gonna be a game-changer.
The new AirPods get an extra hour of battery
life during phone calls, up to 3 hours instead
of 2, but listening time stays the same.
An update we’re happy to see is the switch
to Bluetooth 5, so it now matches the X-line
of iPhones and the Apple Watch Series 4, so
you get increased range, which is huge for
those who like to set their phone down and
move around.
So with that out of the way, let’s get to
who should upgrade.
First of all, if your current AirPods are
in good condition and work great for your
needs, I honestly wouldn’t upgrade.
And if you’re thinking of just grabbing
the wireless charging case, I personally don’t
think it’s worth it.
The wired charging speed is just too dang
quick.
We’re talking 15 minutes of charging for
3 hours of listening time.
I only use my AirPods when I need them for
work, so I literally only plug them in every
2 weeks.
The times when I do use them more often, I
only plug it in once a week, so wireless charging
would be a huge waste for me.
Now if you’re the type that listens to music
literally every day, all day, and you love
using wireless charging, it makes sense.
Otherwise, simply plugging them in every evening
for half an hour will do the job.
The interesting thing is that the wireless
charging case only costs an extra $40 if you
buy the new AirPods instead of $80 alone,
so I would honestly just upgrade to AirPods
2 instead of just buying the case by itself.
Now if you’ve never owned AirPods, now’s
the time, because they have some pretty great
upgrades and they’re the same price as the
original AirPods were.
Trust me, you’re gonna love AirPods, so
order them now before they sell out.
If you own an Apple Watch, AirPods are gonna
be your best friend, since you can easily
adjust the volume with the crown and instantly
take phone calls from your watch, so I recommend
them for any Apple Watch owner.
Now the biggest question many of you are gonna
have is if the sound quality has significantly
improved, and unfortunately, Apple’s website
doesn’t mention any major sound quality
improvements, so we won’t know for sure
until we try them out.
We ordered a pair of AirPods 2 this morning
and the first thing we’ll do is compare
the sound quality to the original AirPods
and Samsung’s new Galaxy Buds, so if you’re
not already subscribed, click that button
to sub now so you don’t miss out on those
videos!
This has been Vadim with Max Tech, thanks
for watching, and we’ll see you in the next
video!